We're going to spend the rest of this course on the details of how to use Power BI.
But first I want to spend a few minutes talking to you
about when you would use it, and more specifically,
when would you use each of the three main components: Power Query,
data models, and Power BI reports?
So first, let's talk about Power Query.
Use Power Query when you need to pull data from multiple data sources,
and that can be either for a single report or
for a data model that you want to generate multiple reports off of.
When you want to change the table structure without changing the source.
When you want to set up auto-refreshes for data to keep it up to date.
Finally, whenever you need to get data in either Power BI or Excel.
Power Query isn't only used in Power BI,
as we've discussed earlier.
This is the same as what you can find in
the get data feature in Excel if you've used it before,
and can also be used to create a Data Flow and PowerBI.com.
So others can access data you want to make it accessible.
The next layer of Power BI Desktop is the data model layer.
Create a data model when you might otherwise
use a lookup function to merge data in Excel,
this might be VLookup,
XLookup, index match, whatever your preferred flavor is.
This is where we would use dimension tables and relationships instead to make
this information available while minimizing any extra work for you or your computer.
When you have a range of calculations that you want to be
able to apply in different contexts or hierarchies.
Say you want to be able to calculate gross profit
based not only on an individual time period,
but also different products, departments, or stores.
In Excel, you may end up making dozens of calculations in individual cells.
Where in Power BI,
you can use just one measure and repurpose it throughout your report.
Finally, when you can identify keys to support those relationships between data sources.
To tie data together with relationships,
you need a way to connect the data between those different tables.
Without this, you may have the need for a data model,
but not the raw materials to make one.
Finally, onto the third layer,
create a Power BI report.
When you want your reports' end users to really be able to dig
in and explore and analyze the data in a visually impactful way.
When you might otherwise make a report with
different versions of the same tables on multiple pages,
and when you have access to a data set,
a data flow, or a data model to support your report.
Like I mentioned earlier,
we'll be going through each of these layers step-by-step throughout the course,
but with a heavy emphasis on the Power Query and
the data model layers that ultimately support every reporting layer.
The reporting layers when I as a bias data plumber,
tend to think of as the ooh,
shiny part of Power BI,
and it's not that the reporting layer isn't incredibly important.
Creating a good user interface and learning how to
story-tell with data is crucial and valuable stuff.
I feel it tends to eclipse
the crucial foundation building that happens to make all that beauty possible.
You don't need to remember all of these details right now.
But it's valuable for you to have a general awareness of where you might apply
these tools so that as you learn more about preparing and modeling data in Power BI,
you're actively looking for opportunities to apply what
you learn in your own role as a Power BI professional.